هذا موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم وقع الرئيس
الروسي
مرسومه رئاسيا بتدابير خاصه ردا على فرض
دول مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي سقفا
لاصار النفط الروسي ويحضر المرسوم توريد
النفط ومنتجاته من روسيا الى الدول
والجهات التي حددت سقفا سعريا ويدخل
المرسوم حيزه تنفيذ اعتبارا من الاول من
فبراير ويظل ساريا حتى الاول من يوليو
المقبل
انا وزير الخارجيه الروسيه موسكو مستعده
لبحث القضايا الامنيه في اوكرانيا وغيرها
من القضايا الاستراتيجيه الكبرى وقد شدد
على انه لا يمكن التواصل مع اداره الا اذا
ادركت واشنطن سلبيه سلوكها الحاليه وانه
لا بدالي لبناء علاقات الاحترام المتبادل
مع روسيا في اوكرانيا
محادثات السلام مع موسكو برعايه الامم
المتحده قالت المتحدث باسم المنظمه
الدوليه انه لا يمكن للامين العامه
الا اذا وافقت جميع الاطراف على ذلك
الرئيس الصربيه الغرب والبانا كوسوفو
بالتامر لاستهداف السكان في الاقليم وامر
بوضع قوته في حاله تاهو بالقسوه واقام
محتجون صرف في مدينه مترو هيتشا المنقسمه
عرقيا شمالي كوسوفو حواجز جديده على الطرق
وسط مخاوف من تصاعد العنف في شمال
التي تضرب الولايات المتحده الى 33 قتيلا
معظمهم في منطقه روفالوا بولايه نيويورك
وقد بلغ عدد القتلى في ولايه نيويورك
35 شخصا هذا هو ذكرته وكاله رويترز ان
شركات الطيران الامريكيه واصلت الغاء
رحلاتها بسبب العواصف
المحكمه العليا الامريكيه باستمرار سريان
العمل بالماده الثانيه والاربعين من قانون
الصحه العامه الذي سمته اداره الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وتجهز الفقره ترضى
طالب اللجوء الذين يعبرون الحدود الجنوبيه
بشكل غير قانوني الى المكسيك حيث يتوجب
عليهم الانتظار لحين النظر في طلباتهم
وقال البيت الابيض انه سيلتزم بتنفيذ قرار
المحكمه مؤكدا ضروره تمرير الكونجرس قانون
اصلاح شامل للهجره
افادت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه بان الشرطه
البرازيليه كشفت وجود قنبله في الشاحنه
وقود قرب مطار العاصمه واوقفت قوته الامن
رجلا من انصار الرئيس السابق جرير
بورسونارو هذا وقال المشتبه فيه انه كان
يريد من حكم البلاد تجري هذه الاحداث
قبيله تنصيب الرئيس البرازيلي المنتخب
[موسيقى]